high up on the moors the wildfire
specialists from west yorkshire fire
service are on high alert
increasingly hot dry weather has created
the perfect conditions for fires up here
and the way they deal with them has had
to evolve
they now use these off-road vehicles
that can reach fires regular engines
can't in terrain like this
location is massive uh up here because
you've no water so we've only got a
limited amount of water so we have to
have water to deal with the fire but
then we've also got a lot of backup plan
and it doesn't take much to start a fire
the message to the public is just you
know be very mindful and careful of what
you're doing in this beautiful
countryside we are on top of the moor
now and the wind is blustery this grass
is very very dry and it wasn't that long
ago that a fire swept up the hillside
over there and came perilously close to
this transmitter which would have wiped
out communications across a huge area
it's another illustration of how these
wildfires are potentially affecting
people way beyond just the countryside
the fires on the moors this summer have
spread to areas not usually affected and
fires like this in a cornfield once rare
have also become more common for the
fire service the causes and the need to
change
is unmistakable we've seen the effects
of climate change developing but what
we've just seen is
radically different a completely
different end of a continuum and if
that's a peep into the future then i
think we've got to go back and we've got
to look at everything we've done to date
and just reassess about whether that's
what we need going forward or whether we
need to do even more and i think that
applies to society as well
the landscape is changing the level in a
reservoir here has sunk so low an
ancient village is visible for the first
time in 70 years
it's been a quiet couple of days for the
wildfire team but with more people out
on a hot weekend they know that's
unlikely to last greg milam sky news
west yorkshire